good morning millennials welcome back to
the toes and happy Wednesday that feels
like a Friday so while it is hump day
and I will sing My Hump Day tune it is
the final day of the week for most of us
because it's Thanksgiving so it is hump
day don't forget to hump someone you
love but also acknowledge the space that
you're in it is the last day of work
before a blessed holiday I love
Thanksgiving hey Jax how you doing I'm
doing great it's such an exciting week
the Wednesday before Thanksgiving is
really one of the peak days of the year
I feel like when you think about it you
realize how wonderful it is but it
doesn't get the hype that it deserves
because everyone's focused on
Thanksgiving even like the Friday after
Thanksgiving but like the Wednesday
before it's all ahead of us we have
everything to look forward to it's
Thanksgiving Eve and I'm really getting
into the spirit this year and it's been
really wonderful I really want to kiss
on the mouth of the person who decided
Thanksgiving would be on a Thursday
would have preferred perhaps a Wednesday
yes but the fact that it's not a Friday
it's not a Saturday it's not a Sunday
it's Thursday which means we get
Thursday Friday and Wednesdays like a
half day no one's really like giving
Wednesday any energy oh I feel like when
today is so full for me I'm so busy
between work stuff and prepping for the
big meal ahead but it's gonna make
tomorrow even more sweet like knowing
how much I put in today and it's gonna
make the whole weekend like really great
I'm feeling really really good about the
season guys I'm feeling good about it
too it's really the most wonderful time
of the year and I'm just excited for all
of us I'm thrilled I'm Overjoyed I'm
feeling humbled honestly
as you should be
Humble Pie
and I know like the Thanksgiving is all
about like you know the pilgrims and
Columbus and I know we've canceled
Columbus okay can I just say how
grateful I am that like we've not taken
that energy to Thanksgiving like I know
I know the story but like I'm I still
want to celebrate not really even for
you know America but for for me well I
feel like it's become less about the
history and more just about being
thankful honestly acknowledging the
space that you're in and being grateful
and it's just a day of the year that we
as a country just take time to say
things for the things in our life of
course it harks back to like being
thankful for America but we're also just
thankful for the things that are going
on for us personally and you know
speaking of
Jax what are you thankful for
and by the way this is like a message if
your family does this where you go
around the table start thinking of your
answers now because you don't want to be
a disappointment like your parents your
grandparents like say something
meaningful so Jax what are you thankful
for for sure but I also feel like it
shouldn't be that hard you know like of
course people because
it's gravy some people hate the question
like an and want to hope no one brings
it up but like just look around like if
you're at a gorgeous Thanksgiving meal
surrounded by loved ones like you have a
lot to be thankful for so true
so I'm thankful for everything every
breath every family member that in my
life like I'm just thankful
I'm thankful for life
I'm thankful for all of those as well
I'm thankful for the toasters I'm
thankful for Diet Coke I'm thankful for
my sis Jax this wonderful business we've
created that I'm living my dream I
really am there's a lot to be thankful
for there really is and I'm thankful for
the stress Brethren because even though
they don't want a world day even though
they don't want to work they are the
reason that we work so hard you know to
give them all the Bully Sticks and
dental sticks and kibble that they are
Hearts could ever want
so true Jax that's beautiful thank you
it's been a great year it's been a great
year for the toast and I'm just looking
forward to really ending the year in a
peaceful even though the end of the year
is like so chaotic for me because like
we the last episode of the toast is
December 16th that's when season five
officially ends and I have one million
things to do before then like before I
can officially wrap up the year but I
have finally put together my holiday
travel plans it took a long time I I was
supposed to go this place and then but I
finally ended up last week or this week
actually finalizing it and I'm really
excited about it I'm excited for you too
you'll have to share all the Deets with
me yeah well me and Ben were supposed to
be going to Perry but then it was like
so expensive so expensive and I'm like
for what like I'm not even Catholic like
I don't even celebrate Christmas like
why do I have to be in Paris for
Christmas and I'm like I have the luxury
of like Carrie and big I have the luxury
of Designing my own life I have my own
business and I don't have any children
like I can go to Paris whenever why am I
going to go at the most expensive time
of year
it's a beautiful time to be in the city
of Lights I know I really and I've never
been like I really want to go
um I was like I'm so
obsessed with you going to Paris Jackie
couldn't believe she was like making fun
of me like making me not want to go no
not that yes first exactly that no first
when you told me that when we were just
like talking about Christmas plans a few
months ago and you told me that you and
Ben were thinking of going to Paris I
fell off my chair I fell off my chair
because you're always a beachfit you'll
always take a beach over a city let
alone like you know a a historic City
that's a lot of you know sightseeing and
I know that's not what you will do all
the time but like you could go anywhere
in the world as you stated you have the
luxury of designing your own life and
like you chose to go to Paris it was a
shocking choice for me but then I
started to get so excited thinking about
like all of the things that I needed you
to do so that I could live vicariously
through you like of course shopping but
also Versailles there's so much great
Royal history there that I would have
loved for you to see and I would I got
really first I was shocked then I and
then I was in denial then I was a little
angry that I wasn't going but then by
the time I reached acceptance I was
really excited for you and now you're
not even going
you did kind of glaze over the mocking
phase but it's fine I'm strong enough to
live without you
um she made fun of me endlessly she knew
that it was the funniest thing like
what's so funny I didn't make fun of you
I just like couldn't stop bringing it up
she made fun I was just like to everyone
like guess where Claudia is going you'll
never guess right no like making fun you
guys but it's fine I didn't go because I
was literally mocked out of it oh my God
stop I sat with you and tried to be
tried to watch certain documentaries
about Napoleon together eventually she
came around she came around
um but I'm not even going anymore so for
nothing I'm so
disappointing let down but I feel like
you'll go now that you have the Parisian
itch I feel like you'll go soon also
it's worth saying I've never been to
Paris so like it was just crazy that you
were gonna do something by yourself
without me like no you were you were
hurting me because you were hurt hurt
people hurt people yeah I think I was
hurt I was obviously shocked I was
probably a little jealous too like
you're going to Paris you're always
going to be the girl the girl who didn't
go to Paris that's gonna go it was just
a lot and I feel like if the toasters
who are listening like because they know
you so well will understand why I was
shook to the core no cause like one
thing about me is like I really don't
like Europe like I don't like those
types of vacations unless it's like the
south of France or Positano you know
bleach excluded Beach exclusion like
vacations that require like walking
tours and history and sightseeing like
that's not how I'm ever gonna choose to
spend my money and my time
um and the only person who hates that
[ __ ] less than me more than me is Ben so
I really wanted to go somewhere I'd
never been before and it's like we've
done every vacation we ever do as Beach
Caribbean beach beach British Virgin
Islands U.S Virgin Islands Turks and
Caicos so we're like let's do something
different we're trying to think of
places we've never been before that
aren't so far I can't go over like eight
hours on a plane unless I'm going to
Israel because I have to connect with my
spirituality but other than that like
I'm never gonna go to South Africa like
I'm never gonna go anywhere that's
double digit flight out even if
Shannon's there
even if Shannon's there wow um even
though you know the Australia family we
are descendants of South Africa so I'm
still never gonna go and
when it came down to choosing a location
it was honestly like on either London or
Paris I could never go to London without
you so I was left with Paris and I'm
like you know what like I could take
some cute pics by the Eiffel Tower eat
french fries smoke cigarettes like Ben
was the only reason Ben wanted to go was
because he wanted to smoke cigarettes
for those French cigarettes for the
French cigarettes like it seemed like
the right choice but then when it came
to time to booking stuff like my first
and let's be real probably only trip to
Paris like I'm doing it up I want to
stay at Muhammad Fayed Dodi and Mohammed
faeed's Hotel I want to say the Ritz
during the holiday uh twenty thousand
dollars like that's not gonna work for
me so
um I have decided now after you know a
lot of hype I'll tell everyone where I'm
going I'm going to Belize
um I'm so excited and I'm going with
Brian which you know I honestly have not
traveled without Brian
since I've met him honestly when I think
back to all the amazing trips I've taken
they're all with Brian it's because
Brian knows how to plan he knows how to
travel he finds like these Great
Destinations that aren't torturous it's
a non-stop flight like he really um I've
become extremely spoiled by being best
friends with the Points Guy and I tried
to travel without him and I couldn't do
it so I'm going with Brian
well that's gonna be so fun I'm excited
for our
um break at the end of the year we do it
every year so if you're in a new toaster
the season ends oh we always take like
the last two work weeks off of the year
um for our respective vacations and I'm
looking forward to a little R and R yeah
I am too and I'm not leaving till you
know the end of the month so I'll have
some nice time at home with Theo and
then a little Adventure in South America
I've never even been to South America
I'm low-key like not well traveled but I
travel a lot although I did come to the
conclusion when I was in Charlotte I did
uh we were on a long car ride and I was
bored I tallied up all the states I've
been to because of tour I was like
curious if have it have I been close to
like 50 of them I've been to 36 and I
think the goal of mine is going to be
going to all 50. that's so cool you
should get a map where you put like you
know I actually I actually have a map
um
it was a gift from someone I no longer
speak to so I don't use it but it's like
a little pinpoint map
um to track my tour it was actually a
very thoughtful gift from a really um
deeply unwell person so I'm looking at a
map to see where Belize is because it's
not where I would have guessed no you're
telling me Belize is not in Spain I
think of Belize as like Ibiza
oh no I was thinking of Belize if I had
to F like if I had to give a guess I
would have probably said somewhere in
the Caribbean
it's not far from and it's not it's
South America it's like by Chile and
Nicaragua but it's not an island I would
have thought it was an island it's not
so where we're staying is an island like
you take a little plane from Belize
what's the name of the island I'm not
entirely sure honestly I guess don't
tell me like exactly where you're
staying on the show yeah no I definitely
won't do that sorry so I'm excited it's
getting caught up in the geography do
you know that Belize is home to the
second largest Barrier Reef in the world
what's the first largest the great Great
Barrier Reef yes the great so is this
the Good Barrier Reef it's the decent
Barrier Reef
and will you be visiting this Barrier
Reef of course I'm gonna scuba and well
I don't scoop a snorkel and I'm so
excited like Brian's really gotten me
out of my comfort zone when it comes to
vacationing like prior to Brian like I
would go on a beach vacation and like
not leave the hotel sit my ass on the
beach with Brian it's like let's go
scuba diving let's take out a boat one
day let's check out these like different
caves like I'm really so adventurous
so adventurous I need Brian to take you
on a ski trip so that you get into
skiing because Brian ski you know what's
so funny I don't think Brian's like
literally too tall to skate I know he's
so athletic I'm sure he's just the type
of person who's like skied a few times
but like if somebody invited him to
Aspen he would be like on the black
diamond and he'd be fine yeah he'd be
perfect that's Brian like he could try
anything and like be perfect at it you
know yeah okay I'm gonna have to like
send him a text to get you to take you
on a ski trip and then I'll come and
then we'll all ski one thing about me is
like I cannot ski the I don't know if
it's the skis themselves or just the
sheer fact that like my shins are
required to hold up my entire body
weight but like I'm physically incapable
I think you could do anything that you
set your mind to I don't think it's true
of which I have set my mind to something
and I'm making such major strides in my
goal and I'm feeling so hashtag proud
driving because I am learning how to
drive I had my first two hour driving
lesson yesterday with the driving school
I'm practicing on my off days but it was
my first like full lesson in the car
with the thing on the hood you know
student driver the whole car is branded
the driver has brakes and gas to the
right and
I was incredible yesterday
I heard that the driver the teaching the
teacher told you that you could pass
today yeah it was so crazy because last
week I drove with Zach just to the
grocery store and I was I never had Zach
take me on a driving lesson before so I
was so surprised at how like calm and
patient he was and like he was really
like I guess he just decided he was
going to be a good teacher and he was
like just being so
level-headed and like really patient
with me and but still I I it's like
jerky and the stops were jerky and I I
didn't feel like I was a very good
driver and it made me like Dread driving
in that I'll never actually enjoy it
because even with like a good instructor
like I just wasn't enjoying it but then
yesterday when I was with like a new
instructor
from the minute like we pulled out your
girl was cruising your girl was so
comfortable like the stop signs jerks
what who and then I was starting to feel
like it was the kind of car so all cars
drive differently and like mastering the
level of pressure you you need to put on
the brake and each car is so different
and it's kind of psychotic yeah no so
like this Mazda was made for me and I'm
so excited for when I do get my license
and I can get a car like now the Mazda's
in the running I'm actually thinking
about getting a compact car instead of a
mid-sized SUV because I liked being more
in control of my vehicle I didn't see
that for myself and
we like we drove for two hours I drove
the entire time we did all of the
different like parking three-point turn
I thought three points were hurting was
going to be like the hardest part of
driving like no it's low-key easy it's
pretty logical it's it's math it's right
left right yeah or left right left or
depending on the turn maybe it is left
right yeah it's left right left you're
right about that uh and I even drove on
the highway share Horowitz the [ __ ]
freeway it was wild and I was so
comfortable and it was really a turning
point for me like in realizing that I'm
going to get my license soon I'm gonna
be driving here there everywhere and I'm
gonna have freedom and I'm really
excited and that's really like I'm sure
there'll be other things that I want to
do in our accomplish in life but there
have been like a few big things over the
years that I've needed to tick off like
cooking look at your girl look at your
girl came through with blind colors and
like driving for the last 15 years has
been stuck at the top of this list and
like once I accomplish publish this like
I'm good I'm just feeling so proud like
no tackles accomplishing yeah tackling
new skills as an adult is so fulfilling
and that's how I felt at one point about
skiing like teaching myself how to ski
as an adult was a huge thing and now I
love skiing and I feel like it could
happen for you well by the way that's
why I was like so emo when I was talking
about reading the other day right it's
this and I feel the same way about
reading for me
yeah like something in my adult life
that I just didn't see for myself so now
once I finished driving like I'm gonna
have to sit down with my Buckingham
Palace planner and think about like what
are other things that I want to learn
how to do in life well a couple years
ago I taught myself how to knit and I
still remember it's like something you
never forget and it's one of my favorite
I don't do it enough but it's one of my
favorite things to do yeah that's a good
hobby
yeah it is a good hobby I don't I'm a
little short on time for hobbies right
now so it needs to be something that's
not just like it has to be functional
too it has to be functional like cooking
I'm feeding the family right
um well while you were feeding your
family last night I finally got to see
that play I've been talking about for
like a month
um called Titanic the musical Titanic
spelled t-i-t-a-n-i-q-u-e
and oh my God it Jackie you would love
so it's like a parody of the the film
okay um with Jack and Rose and Kathy
Bates and they like have all these
characters who play like the Victor
Garber character who played the Kathy
Bates character but it's like nobody
knows those people's names they only
know Jack and Rose so Victor garber's
character's name was Victor Garber it
was so funny it was like this very
satirical
um retelling of Titanic with um
music and all the music was Celine Dion
and Celine Dion was like the host of the
storytelling and the woman who played
Celine Dion first of all had an amazing
voice and did the best Celine Dion I'm
sure accent how are we thank you very
much it was so good I was caca Ling you
know I hate I hate plays like it's just
not my thing but it was 90 minutes no
intermission perfect length Broadway
take notes and it was just it was
hysterical and there were Parts moments
of it where I was like damn like this is
would be even funnier if Titanic wasn't
like an actual tragedy that killed 2 000
people but I did feel like they remedied
that like first of all at the end they
had everyone Sing My Heart Will Go On
like in memory of the people who passed
away it was really sweet and they do
something in them in I don't want to
spoil it but like a part of the plot
that they change like actually it's like
more dignified
um it was just it was amazing I need to
see it again because like like I I need
to just like absorb it once again it was
so good
that's awesome it really was
I'm happy you had a nice night out and
then you went to Rebecca's engagement
party yes and then I headed off to Becky
from the redheads who got engaged last
night we had like a surprise party for
her right after she got engaged
um your presence was sorely missed but
when I tell you I never saw a [ __ ] so
happy in my [ __ ] life like she was
screaming I've been to a lot of
engagement parties and honestly I don't
think I've ever seen a girl so excited
like so happy obviously she was happy to
get engaged but I think she was so shook
that like everyone from her life like
friends from different you know from
Camp from College from home her family
like from out of town everyone was in
town and I think like she was just
really overwhelmed and it was like it
was such a happy night it was a true
simcha oh that's so beautiful uh it
really was I spoke to you guys last
night but I'm gonna call backs again
today I'm so happy for her and we'll be
celebrating on the redheads for sure
we'll be celebrating also redheads
programming update I'll share on our
Instagram but we're gonna drop the
episode a week later than usual for a
few reasons one it will allow us to
record together in person which is
always exciting and two as it is the
last episode of the year we do a whole
Roundup of all the books that we read
this year our top three books that we
each read personally we come we all vote
on the number one two and three redheads
books of the year and so we want to have
that extra week to like read more books
so that we can add it into our Roundup
so stunning second Thursday of December
the redheads will be here
um so that's all the catching up that I
had to do we have a Fab show we've got
five stories but it's also Wednesday and
so we're gonna finish off this week you
know with a little a little Grace we're
going to help our toasters through
whatever it is they're going through we
have some unique deer toasters I want to
say our third and final one is unlike
anything we've ever had and it will tug
at the heartstrings that's what I'll say
oh okay I'm excited to get into that we
have some interesting stories too and I
think it'll be great to carry us into
the Thanksgiving week also just need to
plug one second did you see my pie last
night I did everyone Apple dolce de
leche apple pie Magnolia table recipe
can you believe it I can't your girl
cooked a pie cross it off the list
have you ever made a pie
no it's a lot of work it's hard work the
coal miners could never literally
literally literally
so without further Ado did you wear the
strikes Brethren oh they're cooking the
turkey for Thanksgiving thank you
Brethren it is time for the fast size
stories that you need to know before the
Glorious holiday weekend
and today's episode is brought to you by
Shopify are you ready to Be Your Own
Boss yet because your boss is a wench
start run and grow your own successful
business with Shopify the all-in-one
Commerce platform they make it simple to
sell to anyone from anywhere whether
your thing is vintage tea teas recipes
starting start selling with Shopify and
join the platform simplifying Commerce
for millions of your favorite businesses
worldwide including the toast you know
our merch is on Shopify Jackie O flow is
on Shopify pretty much anything we do
e-commerce wise is on Shopify and I have
to say I've used a lot of platforms it
is by far the simplest the most
effective and just like the most easy to
use they have all the sales channels
sorted so your business can keep growing
from an in-person POS system to an
all-in-one e-commerce platform even
across social media platforms like Tick
Tock Facebook and Instagram and thanks
to their 24 7 support and free libraries
full of educational content shopify's
got you every step of the way it's how
every minute new sellers around the
world make their first sale with Shopify
and you will too so they make selling
simple so you can put yourself and your
ideas out there whether your thing is
making ebooks or earrings Shopify makes
your success possible if you're ready to
launch and do your thing in the
spotlight do it with Shopify you won't
regret it the Commerce platform that is
backed by millions of business including
your girls here at the toast
so if you want to sign up for a free
trial go to shopify.com toast use that
all lowercase shopify.com
t-o-a-s-t to start selling online today
that's
s-h-o-p-i-f-y.com slash toast you won't
regret it and if this is you know
something you've been wanting to do
start your own business perhaps this is
the sign the push that you need
yes
if you didn't know where to start no I
was just thinking about that when you
were reading for Shopify like if you
have an itch to start your own business
if you have an idea but you have no idea
where to start Shopify no and then like
really if that's like your resolution
get everything sorted now start getting
designing on Shopify and then by the
time the New Year it launches like
you're gonna be ready and like your
resolution will already be easy to
complete to execute
so today's episode is also brought to
you by Spritz Society because we have
major news for our patreon members we
are officially 48 hours away from Spirit
society's biggest sale of the year which
is Black Friday have you been waiting
for the perfect time to try Spritz or do
you just want to stock up for the
holidays the moment has finally arrived
they will be 25 off site-wide starting
Friday Black Friday this Friday that's
25 off all of their iconic flavors Peach
grapefruit blood orange pineapple and
lemon but we had to give a little
something special for our stunning
toasters over at patreon so starting
today patreon members will receive an
exclusive Black Friday offer just for
them there's never been a deal like this
it is a bigger deal than the Black
Friday deal that starts Friday if you're
looking for the code and everything go
to the patreon it's already up there you
can shop directly from there
um
I have to say like I'm always trying to
get Ben to increase our code toast and
like margins things like that so he says
no
um so 25 off on spritzociety.com
starting Friday and then like a bigger
percentage off when you're a patreon
member and you can shop right now it's
kind of everything of the sort it's
never too late to sign up for the
patreon sign up now log on start
shopping Spritz society and you can
thank us later
thank you so much mclartia
um two great toast approved tips from
two great girls
let's talk about that
let's I wish someone would
okay are you ready for our first story
that's so [ __ ] twisted it had to be
the first story okay I am but can I talk
about something like about myself really
quickly for One Last Thing Before we
start talking about other people
look at my microphone sure
so yesterday we posted on our Instagram
um a little graphic of you know
Claudia's favorite stories things she's
always repeating yes and a lot of people
had good suggestions for things that we
should add and I think a lot of people
also got confused between this list and
the list of my regrets they're very
different this list is stories that I'm
always telling acting like it's the
first time you guys have ever heard them
yes also there's a difference some
people were writing like stories that
are just like a story that you've told
once it's like a famous story
yeah but so okay yeah that's in like the
but I've only said that once so that's
not one of my favorite repetitive
stories no there's a difference between
like a famous Claudia story and a story
it's like no one could say anything and
Claudia finds a way to bring up this
story that she loves talking about so a
good example of that that we should add
to the list is me being on a boat with
Leonardo DiCaprio I talk about it all
the time it was in my book
um yes I just will say considering like
the magnitude of that you actually talk
about it like it's it's not like you
know Keenan's Uber drivers where it's
like no like okay to hear it once is
enough no I completely agree
okay um also I I don't really talk about
this that much anymore but that other
episode of SVU where the nanny was kept
in the trundle
to maybe just SVU
um
hold on let me keep there was no you
know what I have to be the one to to
determine because I'm the one who
listens to him oh the celebrity
documentary conversation like I do
always like drag Shawn Mendes and praise
Lady Gaga
so [ __ ] true so [ __ ] true like
whenever we're talking about celebrity
documentaries I talk about how like
either you need one Lady Gaga or you
don't need one Shawn Mendes and it's
true
oh my God it's so [ __ ] true you're
always talking about five foot two
um I am always talking about five foot
two also I didn't realize I spoke about
this that much but I must because
somebody was like when Claudius was in
her first year of her communication
course and half the class said they
wanted to grow up and be Juliana Rancic
you've you've only said that like twice
yeah yeah yeah I agree it's not very so
true like everything Jessica Simpson
being your birthday buddy I I just can't
talk about Jessica Simpson without
mentioning that we do have the same
birthday because it's like literally
part of my personality also people who
commented Cuba Gooding Jr like are you
guys okay
I don't really talk about it that much
no not even that but like this whole
this list is like a joke like that's not
a joke no and it's only funny when I say
it no and it's like it's not annoying
that you keep talking about the time
that you were uh oh harassed by Cuba
Gooding Junior Sam Hunt's DUI
okay I do talk about that a lot I feel
like though we're we're straying though
from Dennis's funeral you know that's
like textbook the idea was Megan and
Harry with the umbrella yes so iconic so
literally movie star movie star I'm
gonna have to go through this list and
and edit because okay we're getting your
daughter away I trust you but thank you
to everyone for their um suggestions and
recommendations
yeah like someone suggested banwi and
it's like no that's just a famous
Claudia story I've only told it once say
Paul Rudd but he did she's teach me
gymnastics I literally I'll take that to
the Grave I have to meet Paul right I
have to ask him if you ever worked at
Five Star Gymnastics in Long Island like
Claudia Sumdog millionaire
sweeping the Oscar is totally sweet
that's the perfect example yeah but they
did they swept the Oscars that year oh
here's a great one the tax story
about how you like your first year of
being an influencer taxes do I tell that
story a lot a couple anything was in
your book too it was in my book
um
all the more reason to go purchase a
girl with no job.com book
yes uh there was one other thing that I
just wanted to say and then we can move
on oh The Voice class you took in
college
what do I say about that
I don't know but that's not Dennis's
funeral so but I did take voice lessons
in college here's a story you don't talk
about enough
the time you flush the car keys down for
the rental car in the
Highway bathroom
that's what we don't talk about enough
yeah because she wants us to forget and
some of us can't because I want to
forgive you and I want to forget you
that was a tough day for me that was a
really really tough day for me and by
the way it's not just like the rental
car keys it's the Jaguar car rental car
that we rented to treat ourselves for a
really fun weekend I am waiting for the
day because we just like left that
rental car in some parking lot and like
I believe it's still there Budget rental
car was like yeah we'll come pick it up
um I believe that somebody like one of
these days I'm gonna open up my credit
card bill and there's going to be like a
250 000 charge from budget for like the
car that we never returned
um
now you're going to go to buy a house
and you can't get a loan because you
have dark but God forbid knock wood
actually you check your credit score
though yeah of course yeah and Chase
always lets you know when like when it
drops yeah no nothing has happened yet
and I I like to think that they
retrieved the car but there's truly no
way of knowing unless we were to go
it's probably still sitting in that
Connecticut rest stop because there's no
key you can't even steal it like
damn no you could steal without a key
yeah that's true and we left it open but
yeah
we did leave it open because we didn't
have any key to lock it
he is like in the sewage system so it's
probably still
connected to the ocean now
that's true not me polluting
okay now let's get into our first story
that is so Twisted that it had to be the
first story
Balenciaga apologizes for a bondage
themed campaign featuring a child and an
excerpt from a scotus ruling on child
pornography so Balenciaga has had to
apologize in the last one day for two
instances of sexual misconduct relating
to minors first they have a campaign
that has kids posing for kids clothes
and holding bears that are wearing BDSM
style harnesses which elicited outrage
from people who saw these images and
then some eagle-eyed
viewers internet thought that one of
their photos that they posted is one of
their bags on a pile of documents on a
desk and the documents are actually the
ruling from a Supreme Court ruling that
relate to child pornography and actually
upheld part of a part federal child
pornography law so Balenciaga issued a
statement and they appear to be
langblame at the photographer and are
vowing to sue the photographer but their
statement said
we apologize for displaying unsettling
documents in our campaign we take this
matter very seriously and we are taking
legal action against the parties
responsible for creating the set and
including unapproved items for our
spring 23 campaign photo shoot we
strongly condemn abusive children in any
form we stand for children's safety and
well-being I just feel like if you get
into a place where you have to um say
abusive children in any form as if it
was up for debate
um you got a problem no here's what's
like I saw at first like the pictures of
the kids I'm like that's just like
really bad judgment I think like
while it's inexcusable I could see how
like people would like not think of it
or whatever I could see how maybe it
slipped through the cracks but then that
paper with the scotus thing I'm like
this is layered this is like a
conspiracy like maybe signaling to all I
don't know it's [ __ ] weird
no like there is at least one
child abuser who is working at
Balenciaga or on this campaign like
working through the photographer
whatever like root him out or her no
it's a very it's very disturbing this is
like not it's giving him obviously but
also when they had to apologize for the
for the Bears thing that was a separate
um Instagram story and they said our
plush Bears shouldn't our plush bear
bags should not have been featured with
children in this campaign but it's like
why who are the Bears for if not
children so who are you making a BDSM
bear for if you're making it for adults
who are then still have files who are
into bears no fuzzies is what they call
themselves furries furries uh furries if
you're into stuffed animals that's a
thing but I didn't know that Balenciaga
was like making swag for the furries
Community it's pretty Niche audience no
it's definitely a different strategy
something we've never seen before it's
tough that's a competitive competitive
market that luxury luxury stores but the
thing is is like
um
like this is like not okay it's not
normal I don't know what the [ __ ] these
people are thinking and every now and
then you know like a brand will get
backlash
um and sometimes I feel as though you
know people are being dramatic or like
looking into it or like you could really
see a world where a bunch of idiots
didn't really didn't realize this is so
like not to sound like a conspiracy
theorist but [ __ ] Twisted Twisted and
calculated it seems so intentional and
subtle
um like they didn't think anyone would
zoom in and read the copy of the papers
in the background of this product shot
I'm so turned off
by this brand I think it's it's in it's
just not okay I can't think of any other
words I'm sorry yeah I think there's two
different conversations to be had I
think the documents thing is so Twisted
that doesn't happen by accident now
whether it's someone who is like
researching child pornography laws and
then those were the documents in the
office that they put on the desk maybe
or like it's some intentional person
like signaling like hey hey subliminal
messages hey look at me like yeah that's
so [ __ ] twisted and I feel like one
child pornography and like child abuse
and pedophilia is so rampant in like the
world and it's so crazy to me we talk
about like I can't even wrap my head
around
how all the sex trafficking it's
incredible people a year
and then you see [ __ ] like this and it's
like it's even more prevalent than you
could possibly know and then there's the
other thing where it's yes as you said
like uh a judgment error but if your
judgment error is BDSM in children and
mixing the two you need help no you are
sick I feel like kids are just they just
the line just keeps moving and of course
this this crosses the line for everyone
but the fact that anybody thought that
thought it was okay themes could
collaborate for a shoot like we are sick
people
no it's well not me very it's very
disturbing it's not you if you're a
toaster but you 100 World At Large no
it's it's very disturbing and I think we
must protect the kids we got to protect
the kids nobody's protecting the kids um
actually the kids are I feel like less
protected than ever the people are using
like kids to protect adults yeah
protect the children in all way shapes
and forms amen let kids be kids and if
you have to ask BDSM and and children
they don't drive no they do not
so I'm actually not that I'm I don't
think I'm a Balenciaga girly I actually
think their shit's pretty ugly I own
anything if I was ever tempted though
like I'm out like you guys need to do a
full investigation into the rampant
pedophilia in your company agreed
because if it's making it into like the
consumer-facing advertising
it runs deep yeah that's true
so figure your [ __ ] out um
are you ready for our next story yes
positive wonderful news
cheers star Gabby Butler signs with the
WWE that's a mouthful the WWE she said I
never thought cheerleading would take me
this route
cheers dark Abby Butler is ready to take
athleticism to a new sport the longtime
gymnast has officially signed a contract
with WWE she exclusively shares with
People magazine Gabby says she fell in
love with wrestling this summer after
attending SummerSlam in Nashville she
said I was blown away by what they put
on she admitted that she never
considered the sport she was focusing on
cheer she said I was so involved in
cheerleading in the cheerleading
industry for so long and I never really
looked into anything other than
cheerleading but when I went to
SummerSlam it really just opened my eyes
to the athleticism and the dedication
the athletes bring into the ring she
says she admired the way they performed
and the competitive atmosphere which
isn't so different from her experience
in cheerleading it was almost like I was
watching a cheerleading competition but
wrestling Edition
you know one of the huge takeaways I had
from Cheer the documentary was like how
much of a shame it is that there's not
really a life for a professional adult
cheerleader it's it's a sport that ends
at the college level and it's like what
do you do after all that training you're
21 you've given your whole life to the
sport and you have to go and get a job
like in a restaurant or in marketing
like it's like it's not what you had
been training for and I never really
thought about this as an option and I
have to say I think this makes a [ __ ]
ton of sense and I actually think this
is an amazing next step for Gabby Butler
amazing Next Step It makes so much sense
I can't believe it's not been thought of
before or maybe there have been like
professional cheerleaders who go into
WWE but they weren't famous before from
Cheer because there was no big
documentary about them so we don't know
but I think that this is so awesome I
think this is great for Gabby's career
because she can continue doing what
she's doing and in the spotlight and I
think it's great for WWE because I think
it will bring a new audience she has
such a huge audience a young audience
and I think that on all fronts like
what would uh this has the girl boss Tam
Town stamp of approval gbt step of
approval yeah
um but also the WWE has been just kind
of killing it recently in their castings
like they cast Logan Paul and I think
that was amazing for them because Logan
Paul has become you know somewhat of
like a figure in the wrestling space and
he has such a huge young International
audience and I think Gabby Butler is
just like another a plus
casting for them I think this is great
for real yeah and she will definitely
have the chops I think there's a little
more she'll have to learn like
especially about the like perform like
the staging the theatrics but
I think she will be very successful did
you check your DMs this morning did you
see that um there's a big toaster in uh
WWE Diva Community she dm'd us this
morning
be right back why don't you show it to
me like you're in the chat and so I
figured and I responded to I thought you
would see it she was like loving the
toast and she's a really big WWE Divas
so um shout out and that was exciting to
see this morning it's just a WWE sort of
day you know when that happens for sure
I don't see a single thing in my DMs but
I'll look into it deeper later okay it's
cool stuff that's just you
um I know how Instagram DMS work okay
I didn't see it you're blind I'm sorry I
don't think I'll send it to you I I love
Gabby Butler and I feel like she has you
know done everything she can do until a
certain age like she transferred to
multiple colleges she did like these
summer programs she keeps doing what she
can to like get on squads Gabby Butler
is like the most educated woman in
America because she keeps going to
college a junior college a senior
college a four-year program a two-year
program a summer program she keeps
joining different programs to get on
different squads because there's really
nowhere to go after college so she is
just taking her time getting her degree
and I love it I really do yeah she's
getting her degree on her own time
do you think she'll cheer for Education
Connection next year that's what
Education Connection needs they need a
commercial with Gabby Butler
gbt stamp of approval
so yeah some some news that makes sense
today you love to see it some athletic
news
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
beekeepers Naturals oh yes we have been
using propolis every day to help support
our immune systems and keep our bodies
healthy when we start to feel run down
which can be really common in the winter
time so um the propolis immune support
throat spray has been a daily ritual for
me because I have throat problems like
I'm very immune to strep I always have a
sore throat like on cold days I'll wake
up with a sore throat and I find that
like being proactive with the propolis
immune support throat spray from
beekeepers Naturals has really made a
huge difference
um it can help soothe my sketchy or
irritable throat so propolis is made by
bees which we just know like anything a
b makes is gonna work you know
it's made by bees and it's backed by
science so B propolis acts as the bees
medicine and it also contains vitamins B
vitamin C zinc over 300 beneficial
compounds and minerals that are amazing
for the human immune system propolis is
the defender of the hive and bees use it
to protect their high from any bacteria
that might harm them it's basically the
hive's immune system and so medicinal
use of propolis dates way back to before
300 BCE in the times of Aristotle
Aristotle is thought to have coined the
word propolis which means defender of
the city so beekeepers Naturals has
given us an exclusive Early Access to
their Black Friday sale which is the
biggest sale of the year when you go to
beekeepersnaturals.com toast or use
co-host at checkout to get Early Access
and receive 30 off-site wide so stock up
on their products now before they sell
out also we're just entering the winter
months and I feel like that's when
everybody's like immunity goes to [ __ ]
and they really need that good stuff in
their house to be stocked up on so Black
Friday is a great excuse to get all your
favorite beekeepers natural products I
um I think I found out about the throat
spray from Lauren Boston a few years
maybe like a year ago and it's really
made a huge difference I'm just I'm like
a bad I have a bad throat I don't know
what it is beekeepers natural products
are also available at Target Whole Foods
CVS and Walgreens but if you want to
start feeling better every day do that
today at beekeepersnaturals.com toast
and use code toast at checkout to get
early access to their 30 off site-wide
Black Friday sale
wonderful thank you McLarty it's so
important to keep your immunity up this
time of year it's wild out there it's
wild out there
our next story Julia fox says she dated
Kanye to get him off of Kim's case do
you see Julia's Tick Tock so it's been
real I was thinking about it this
morning actually because this is just
the nature of the internet Julia Fox
became really popular on Tick Tock like
two months ago when people were like
saying and commenting you know Julia Fox
is really not what we thought she is
she's an intellect she's a woman who
supports other women like they were
gassing her up you know like living for
it and you know what the internet giveth
the internet must take it away so then
it was like the narrative started to
change it's like well how great can
Julia be if she dated Kanye he's a
misogynist so it's like now her fault to
everything Kanye has done
um and so she is being like super
transparent responding to comments being
like this is what I think about this and
this is my response to this not doing
any like formal statements or anything
she was like I was going to put this all
in my book but you know what like let's
just get into it now yeah so she really
got into it I was surprised at like how
I never heard her talk so into one long
stretch like that even though and it
just felt like she was being really
honest and like talking about like
the a thing that everybody wants to know
about which was like that one month
because even though we watched that
interview of her on call her daddy I
feel like we didn't get um no I feel
like the interview on caller Daddy was
actually like a really poor
representation of who she actually is
especially because the only thing people
took away from that was Uncle Jam right
now nobody was more like extremely well
read and really smart it was like her
life story but at the time she was
dating Kanye they broke up like two days
later and so she wasn't really talking
about dating Kanye like yeah and what
that was like so it was uh it felt to me
like the First full picture that we saw
of it so she talked about like how they
got together she said I remember he was
texting me and I wasn't really answering
and I didn't want to talk to a celebrity
again because nothing ever comes of it
it's boring and they're not what you
think they're going to be like so true
she noted that she realized Connie
wasn't giving up and that's when she
realized that she may be doing his
ex-wife a favor by answering she said
then I had this thought I was like oh my
God maybe I can get him off Kim's case
and get him to like me and if I knew
anyone could do it it would be me
because when I said to my mind to
something I do it and she talks about
when how when he was with her like he
was really normal and he wasn't
bothering Kim and he wasn't tweeting and
he wasn't on social media and then when
he did do all of those things she was
out
so let me just say I don't believe that
I don't believe Julia Fox's impetus and
only impetus for dating Kanye was to be
a friend to Kim like I just I'm not well
she talks also in the video how like
she's always admired the Kardashians
they bought her clothes
10 years ago yeah and we know that we
know that because like when she popped
off then people started finding like any
time she's ever said anything about the
Kardashians and she's a huge fan because
she's obviously a woman of taste I feel
like when factoring her decision to date
Kanye maybe it
could maybe it was five percent Let's
Help Kim maybe it was maybe it was one
percent yeah twenty percent Birkin
no but also like look what became you
know no maybe it was 50
the opportunities this could provide it
girl of fashion she goes to every
fashion show she walks in fashion shows
she's literally in magazine spreads her
podcast is huge now she's huge on Tick
Tock like
that's what happens when you date Kanye
not to like strip her down to that her
is her only accomplishment she's
obviously very accomplished but the only
reason I know who she is and the only
reason why millions of people know she
is is because of Kanye and that's fine I
and you would do it too for a check like
I understand like I would do it
um yeah
it's a platform but also
I think there's also something about her
that people have grabbed like people are
obsessed with or the industry is
obsessed with because Kanye has been
spotted yes over
um you know the course of the last few
years since they were divorced and even
before he even met Kim and like what
Julia where she is is kind of a
remarkable precedented no I completely
agree I think like once we all got to
nowhere I was ready to write her off
like once Kanye was like all right this
is the end of the Julia Fox chapter but
she kept popping up and everything I was
seeing I was like she's kind of wacky
she's really smart she's got Charisma
there's something there there's a star
quality there which is why like you know
people on Tick Tock are obsessed with
her
um but we'd be remiss if we didn't at
least acknowledge that that's all
because of Kanye yeah like where we met
her but I think that happens to other
people all the time they have like a
moment and then they make the most of it
and they're here to stay you know
because they have that star quality
that's like that reminds me of emrata in
the music video yeah you know you forget
that that's where you saw her first and
so many other girls are in famous music
videos and they're just like that but
now you actually forget that's where you
first met her and she's Mason Ramsey she
has so many other things no Mason Ramsey
will always be like the boy yodeling I
know not to me though to me he's just
like a really talented young sweet kid
who yodeled in Walmart
right but I do often forget
really yeah I don't think of him as the
Walmart yodeling kid mostly because he's
grown up so much he actually looks so
different I think of him as like the
viral yeah no the Walmart yodeling kid
but like he it does so much more still
but I don't think
and I don't think that you should ever
separate him from that but I think for
like Julia and emrata like those were
like launching pads they and but they
stuck around it's what they've made of
it yeah right and I think there's a lot
of people who have gone viral especially
for singing and a lot of them don't have
the Chokehold that Mason Ramsey has on
our culture yes yeah that was the point
I was trying to make got it okay I
understand it's a separate but different
point but I understand no I think it's
the same point no
that's not the initial Point like now
you're gaslighting me because you know
the point we were saying was like people
who get a platform everyone gets a
platform but like in order to stick
around you gotta have something
and that's literally Mason Ramsay but
what I was saying was you actually
forget what that initial small thing was
that they did because they've done so
much more since you were saying and you
said
and then you said like Mason Ramsay so
like Mason Ramsey yeah but we can't
forget
I can forget I don't even think about
Walmart but maybe that's because I'm
such a Mason fan
I don't think anyone's a bigger Mason
fan do you still think there's a Walmart
yodeling kid like I think of him as like
Old Town Road I think of him as like you
know teenage heartthrob I think of him
as like the viral internet yodel country
singer who's done amazing things and it
still has his sanity
um on my way
I don't wanna take for granted this
ground on which I'm standing his music
is so good that that one song is it's
very beautiful on my way up the mountain
I wanna look around and take in every
sunset before it fails he's gotta get
the little yodel in there if you like
country music listen to on my way by
Mason Ramsey you're gonna be really
surprised with what you hear it's
actually a perfect Thanksgiving song
like it's all about slowing down looking
around digging in what's happened to you
being grateful for all that you have
it's really beautiful it's about
acknowledging the space here in quite
literally
are you ready for our next story yeah
it's another space you could be in
Taylor Swift's Cornelia Street rental
townhouse hits the market at forty five
thousand dollars a month after the home
served as inspiration for the track
about her early days of her romance with
Joe Alwyn so Taylor's iconic Cornelia
Street townhouse has hit the rental
market in London for an eye watering not
London I'm sorry the West Village you
know what all this time I thought it was
in London and then I saw it was located
in the West Village and I thought that
was London too oh my God you've been out
of New York for a month are you okay no
because you know how all like New York
neighborhoods are they have Soho Chelsea
there's also in London oh and I'm sure I
never thought about that and I also just
assumed like it was Joe she had a house
in London on Cornelia Street I literally
to In This Moment just learned that
Cornelius Street is about Manhattan and
not London no but there's that line in
the in the um Bridge about being in the
tunnel and turning around like she was
literally in like the Hudson I mean the
Lincoln Tunnel and like went back you
know well are there not tunnels in
London what about the tube I don't know
but like we call in New York it's like
the tunnel you know no but like they
might have a tunnel well one I don't
know but they don't call it the tunnel I
don't know the lyrics As intimately as
you do but that wouldn't I wouldn't hear
the tunnel and be like was this set in
New York like I just to me it just was
set in London it's like the album of
London boy and it's just a London album
well it's not with London Tings I'm
shocked Claude go rent this townhouse in
the West Village I know the thing is is
like I've seen pictures of the inside
it's beautiful there's like a pool which
is unheard of yeah there's a pool
literally one of the fugliest things
I've ever seen in my life it's like this
purple looks like a carriage house I do
believe it is like a former Carriage
House from like you know gilded times
from the next door neighbor yeah right
that was converted into an actual home
and it's beautiful on the inside but
like it's genuinely one of the ugliest
houses I've ever seen that's so funny
because when I was reading the article
earlier it said that she was living here
while her Tribeca Apartment was being
renovated and I just thought to myself
she had to go to London because her
apartment was renovated but I was like
maybe it was an excuse to take a trip
that's so funny no it takes place in New
York this whole story just changed for
me but I kind of liked it better when it
was in London no well it's never been in
London for me so I'm fine
but now think about it because I thought
then you could rent this house in London
like you don't need to rent a house in
New York you have a house in New York
but you could go to London for a month
rent it see what's going on what's so
crazy is like when lover and this is
just a true Testament to like the
economic times because when lover first
came out like everyone like found the
house I remember seeing it was like 22
000 a month but like inflation and like
you know the economy and the rental
market in New York like all these
factors it's doubled now it's [ __ ]
crazy I know
wow
you should go take a tour as a
prospective renter totally and I can
give you one week of rent
no not even that just act like you're a
big wig yeah
and then be like honestly it's not nice
enough for me who needs a swimming pool
and leave yeah like oh this pool is like
kind of gross yikes yikes you think
they've drained the water or Taylor's
like I think there's Taylor juice in
there yeah I think there's chili cheese
too why would they it's also indoors
like harder to do all of that and you
don't drain your pool that you don't
drain it between renters
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yes ma'am it's just a little
Thanksgiving hack for all of the hosts
and guests out there and it's from tick
tock's Grandma Babs Barber Club
has a brilliant hack for taking
Thanksgiving leftovers to go have you
seen this I saw it and I feel like
everyone needs to know the social the 74
year old social media influencer the
grand fluency
she's really obsessed with she has
amazing hacks and this one's actually
life-changing for giving guests
Leftovers on the big day use disposable
cupcake tins so you set up a leftover
station when everyone's done eating and
have your guests help themselves using
like muffin tins that are disposable
like they can foil material tin foil
material they could take a helping of
everything and then the next day they
put the whole thing into the oven they
get hot delicious no dishes and you
don't have to give away all of your
Tupperware that's the thing it's like
for me I am either living in a time of
Tupperware abundance or Tupperware
depletion there is no in between it's
just like how many how many people have
I had over and how many other people's
homes have I been to in the last couple
of months and that will dictate my
Supply yeah I'm actually low because I
was cooking so much and I was bringing
over like cookies for Kayla all the time
and I I have the new Tupperware arriving
today in preparation for Thanksgiving
because I know that everyone's going to
want leftovers but silly old me should
have just gotten these muffin tins which
I will do actually that's very smart and
very
um classic Babs like just making our
life easier if you don't follow Babs
like she's a great fellow she has
amazing recipes and also hacks and she's
just precious amazing hacks especially
for hosting Thanksgiving like for large
quantities of like peeling washing Etc
like her I am already going to implement
some of her so I just thought I would
leave everyone on that note make sure to
bring your own if you're a guest or a
host bring your own muffin tin yeah but
also I do feel like sometimes people
like shove you out the door with
leftovers and it's like it wasn't even
that good the first time no thank you
like how do you politely say no to
leftovers oh of course well you could
say like that you are on a diet and like
you'd Splurge tonight but like you can't
you can't be oh that's a good one
um
or yeah I would just go with that
honestly
it's like yeah that's a really good one
or take it and like
me and Ben sometimes like if we'll take
Ben's has this thing where like if he
like doesn't like his meal at a
restaurant and like doesn't send it back
he'll just take it to go be like I'm so
full but it was so good I'll take it
home and it's like a full ass meal and
then if there's someone like living on
the street or something like you'll just
give it to them it's like totally full
yeah that's really nice you could do
that too with leftovers yeah totally
um so thank you Jackie for you know
ringing in the holiday weekend with with
a nice little hack yet welcome also
Pacquiao wonderful Thanksgiving content
Claudia and I are recording today our
annual Thanksgiving dinner table patreon
episode this is the fast five stories
that you need to know to navigate the
conversation at your Thanksgiving dinner
table they will be very
um interesting but also neutral it's not
not polarizing I don't know if they're
like a neutral because some of this you
know everything is layered everything
we're going to give you the facts that
you need to know to also be able to hold
a conversation at the Thanksgiving
dinner table and know what the [ __ ]
everyone's talking about yeah exactly
um but before that before we record that
it is time for deer toasters our weekly
advice segment where you guys write in
and we do our best to help the girlies
out we pick three every week so if yours
hasn't been chosen yet
um stay tuned and if you have something
you want to write in about it's
deertoesters gmail.com and dear toasters
is brought to you by away away as a
travel company that believes that the
more we travel the better we all become
so that's why they make suitcases bags
and other travel accessories designed to
make moving through the world a lot
easier so they have fabulous suitcases I
have a ton I know Jackie has a ton it's
really the best and only option when it
comes to travel
um and they're offering a a I can't even
speak away offers a range of suitcases
bags other travel Essentials that are
made for different types of Travelers
whether you're an overpacker a
minimalist a travel expert or anything
in between with its versatile collection
of suitcases bags and travel accessories
away offers the perfect holiday gifts
for every traveler all of their
suitcases are built to last with durable
lightweight exteriors that can withstand
even the roughest of baggage handlers
every suitcase comes with an interior
organization system that includes a
built-in compression pad to help you
pack more they have four 360 degree
spinner wheels that guarantee the
smoothest roll and even a TSA approved
combination lock that keeps all of your
belongings safe they also have a 100 day
trial on everything that they make so
take the product out on the road live
with it travel with it get lost with it
for 100 days and if you decide that it's
not for you you can return any
non-personalized item for a full refund
during that period
um they offer free shipping and Returns
on any orders within the contiguous I
can never pronounce that word contiguous
contingents
no extra n no contiguous
contiguous U.S Europe Canada and
Australia except for the personalized
products and cyber week they're having
their best deal of the Year 50 off any
two or a hundred dollars off of any
three suitcases so it's a great time to
stock up all of their color styles and
sizes are included their offer ends
November 28th visit awaytravel.com to
score yours your toasters is also
sponsored by Noom people will try almost
anything to lose the weight insane
workouts eating nothing but grapefruit
questionable teas but if you're looking
for a more sustainable approach NuMe
weight is ready to help their
psychology-based approach empowers you
with knowledge and support to build
lasting results because you can erase
your past or change who you are but new
weight gets that and everyone's journey
is different each person has a different
goal instead of demanding the same
strict regimen or drastic changes for
everyone you will get a personalized
program that empowers you to build more
sustainable habits that's how they've
helped more than 3.6 million people and
Counting lose weight Noom is proven it's
effective they have an amazing online
food database they also have a great
community so while you're going through
it it can be hard sometimes talking and
engaging with other people who are going
through the exact same thing is actually
really really helpful on the journey if
you if you're done trying everything to
lose weight then just try new weight you
can sign up for your trial today at
noon.com toast that's n-oom.com toast to
sign up for your trial today check out
noom's first ever book the new mindset a
deep dive into the psychology of of
behavioral behavioral change it's
available for pre-order wherever books
are sold
all right dear toasters thank you to
everyone who has written in this week
and here we go and away we go hey
Jackson Claude I have some office drama
that I need your help with we had our
first in-person company happy hour since
before covid and needless to say people
got very drunk I decided to leave before
things got too crazy but the next day I
had several different sources tell me
that my good work friend who just got
married was seen by her employees and
her co-workers making out with another
guy at the back of this hotel and it
even they even disappeared together for
a long time before I found this out I
even talked to this around the morning
after and she mentioned none of this
happening I'm sure if she even remembers
do it I'm not sure if she even remembers
doing this do I tell my friend that
people around the office are saying this
about her behind her back or do I just
let it be and keep pretending that I
don't know EXO a confused co-worker
two questions one like how good of
friends are you guys in two how many
people know that you know could you get
away with pretending like you don't know
and making it not your problem
considering like this is your workplace
and you don't need to be getting
involved in people's personal players I
would avoid any sort of like inter-work
gossip and drama at all costs like I
just think deny uh yeah I honestly
wouldn't tell her maybe she doesn't
remember maybe she does remember or
doesn't like this is her problem maybe
the less people like maybe she can
hopefully convince herself that no one
knows and if you're the only one to tell
her then like it just gets you're
bursting a bubble considering these are
your work friends
um I would just keep a professional you
know it's a very rare occurrence when
you make a work friend that is a real
friend a lifelong for the most part like
this is work this is not personal like
we're here to work and these people are
not your friends so act accordingly no I
completely agree about it let this be a
lesson to everyone like never have more
than two drinks at a work happy hour
like nothing good is gonna come of it
that's the lesson especially as we head
into holiday season especially we head
into a quality parties you guys if you
want to avoid having to write into
unburning yourselves into your toasters
do not have more than two drinks at the
work holiday party and do not be the
last one there every time and go out
with your real friends right no make
plans for after so you get a little buzz
at the Holiday party and then you get to
go out with like your real friends it's
a stop along the way it's not the
destination uh that's such a good
[ __ ] if you take any advice from us
ever please let it be do not get drunk
at work events you will nothing good
comes from it and this is your job and
you need your job and you don't want to
jeopardize it you don't want to feel
awkward at the place that you're working
like you should work on these people
totally
totally it's all outside so that's also
like this isn't your best friend so you
don't feel this like obligation to help
her through this like it's her [ __ ]
problem you know she made her bed let
her lay in it and you're I think you're
off the hook like I would stay out of it
stay out of it
dear Jackson Claude this is a crazy
story ready okay seven of my friends had
planned to go to the Taylor concert
together but you can only buy a maximum
of six tickets we had planned to buy a
set of four seats and then three seats
together obviously it turned out to be
harder than we thought to get through
the queue so the one person who actually
got through just bought six together
there were four out of the seven of us
who actually sat in the queue opened
Capital One cards did whatever we could
to get pre-sale Etc it was determined
that we would draw names out of a hat to
determine who gets a ticket but am I
crazy for thinking that the four of us
whose asses sat in the queue for hours
that we should get tickets immediately I
suggested this and it was like I had
four heads we ended up just drawing
names and the girly who put her literal
heart and soul into trying to get
tickets was the odd man out so I have
given my spot to her but secretly I'm
devastated that the girls who did
nothing didn't volunteer must be nice to
do literally nothing and get to see
Taylor am I psycho for being low-key
like so mad sincerely a loyal toaster
just trying to see Taylor girl you are
so [ __ ] Justified and the fact that
the friend group didn't immediately draw
three names instead of all seven is so
awesome ethical
what two names they would need to draw
well yeah put three in a hat instead of
putting all seven yes yes it's so
unethical it's unfair and I demand a
recount I send this episode to them
that's so wrong on so many levels the
girls who worked hard and did in the
queue and did all that [ __ ] and opened
up their credit like sorry they go and
the three of you lazy [ __ ] two of you
get to go right I also imagine that the
four who tried the hardest are the
biggest fan so they want to go the most
and let me ask you something is the
person who actually bought the tickets
did they immediately get to go or right
who put her credit card they have to
draw two that is so crazy and foolish
and by the way like this isn't binding
in any way shape or form like it should
be redone and why won't the four girls
you guys are the majority the girls and
together for tickets why won't you guys
band together and the girl the the four
girls who who banded together if they
band together they have the one girl who
actually physically has the tickets
possession is nine tenths of the law
they have all the power I would say redo
just be like you guys this isn't sitting
right with me Jenny should be able to go
she sat online all day like no offense
you know Susan Larry Tracy like Tracy
Tracy
like you guys didn't put in the work do
you you didn't like and you guys should
feel weird about the fact that you're
gonna take a ticket from someone who
really wants to go honestly I'm not
going if this is the way that we're
going I don't want this to become the
friend group but like it's wrong it's so
wrong it's so unethical like that's the
perfect word it goes against all that is
right and I'm mad on your behalf you are
so valid in your feelings and I wouldn't
want to go with these girls I would say
I'm not going the girl who has the
tickets should sell them all and
everyone can go like fend for themselves
big rock the girl should sell three of
them she'd double her profits the four
girls but the girl isn't even on her
side it seems because when she suggested
it like everyone thought she was crazy
send this to the girls the four send
this to the four like you need to band
together those other three are lazy
that's that that's that there's there's
no moral ambiguity here no no what's
right is right and what's wrong is wrong
and this is clearly wrong
but look at Taylor like go putting these
friends dividing women
so our third and final dear toasters is
like a little long it's longer than we
would normally do but it's so
interesting
um and it involves you know a stress bro
so we we have to we have to help okay
third and final dear toasters let's get
into it
hello Jackson Claude I always wanted to
have something to write in about and I
[ __ ] around and I found out
I'm desperate I need advice urgently and
I don't want to get my friends or family
involved in the mess so I'm running to
my amazing circle of cyber friends to
help I've been married for seven years
and I got a dog a little bit over a year
ago my husband did not think it was a
good idea to get a dog and he said I'd
have to take full responsibility of the
puppy if we got one meaning meals walks
training Etc fast forward a year and of
course now he's in love with the dog
let's call him Theo and he's been
helping out here and there since I got
Theo I had planned to get him fixed as
soon as he turned one my husband is now
feeling really strongly about not fixing
him we've been talking about it for
months in the hopes of convincing him
making lists of pros and cons Etc still
neither of us are willing to budge I
went ahead and made an appointment for
Theo to get fixed today and last night
my husband said he was going to take him
on a walk and came back without him
says he won't let me mutilate Theo and
would rather give him away than let me
go through with it he won't tell me
where Theo is and I'm heartbroken so
much so that I packed a bag and left our
apartment for the night to stay at a
hotel what do I do I'm sure Theo was
fine and that I'll see him again but
this is a crossing a line right divorce
is not going through my mind but a
simple fight
and giving up sounds wrong too as much
as he is helping out Theo was always my
dog and I feel so powerless now what
should I do I don't even know what
options should be on the table like a
police report divorce folding and not
fixing Theo am I being overly dramatic
thank you girls from a toaster who is at
a loss for words P.S this is not like my
husband he's not psycho generally and is
usually pretty rational
this is some psychotic [ __ ]
Behavior I've never heard of anything
like this for me like this shows
a really bad side of your husband like
this is so manipulative and so childish
and where is the dog
yeah this is really really weird I have
a few questions but like the first thing
that comes to mind is like I'm assuming
they don't have kids yet but someone who
would do this like with a dog like it
just makes you worried about having kids
with them because right if you want to
do something for your child one day and
your husband disagrees and so he's going
to take the trial from you right until
you come around to his she's treating
you like a child my only question is
like if you're saying this is so out of
character and like this is so shocking
and you don't really want to weigh
divorce and if you do want kids but now
you can't have kids with him if this is
something that he thinks is a normal
thing to do then you would probably have
to get divorced my question is like what
is his reasoning against fixing him it
it seems like he has this like a really
really strong moral like what is it it's
just because like that's not what he
wants for him or like there's some like
deeper this is like a hill that he needs
to die on this is his cause maybe he's
like an activist again it's like fixing
mutilation no yeah because the thing is
like at the core of his argument like
you're right like dogs really should be
fixed there's like a number of health
benefits and what are you going to start
breeding dogs in your garage like dogs
are already like an overbred species
like that's why we fix them that's why
they get spayed and neutered
um so I agree with you on the mutilation
if you will
so not only is he wrong there he's
doubling down and doing something that
is so like evil yeah no it's like
honestly argument to fix him or not fix
him like I don't really I mean I don't I
don't think there's like a right or
wrong it's a personal preference but the
idea that like because he didn't get his
way this is how he responds is extremely
insane
and
I think that it's a much bigger issue
than just like he
hid the dog for a night and where but
also like you guys have a lot of friends
and family where he is or is he
where the [ __ ] is he like I need to know
what he did so I feel like in terms of a
plan you need to concede on the
fixing just to get the dog back if
that's like we have to get the dog first
she'll be like all right you know what
I'm so miserable I won't do it get the
dog back in your house take the [ __ ]
dog pack a bag and get out
um and then we'll come up with a plan
like you need to ensure that the dog is
returned safely that's the number one
priority here because like this man
knows how much the dog means human is
like punishing You by withholding it
that's like low-key evil and I know
you're not considering divorce but like
this is really like a like a psychotic
thing to do and really like indicative
of a very manipulative side of him
yeah this is a really psychotic thing to
do I think you need to find get the dog
back so cancel the appointment again
like whether you guys wind up fixing him
or not fixing him whatever relevant even
if he was able to like come into using
his words like it's not even about
I love how he's making this decision for
a dog he didn't even [ __ ] want oh of
course and that's just you know the
cherry on top but even if it was equally
their dogs like that's not how you
respond when you're not getting your way
and that's the concerning part so I
think get the dog back table the fixing
conversation and then you need to really
assess like maybe now in considering
this like there are some other things
that he's done in the past that you're
seeing differently like right this is
because this is serious and also like
I think that you need to like
considering what he did was so serious
like you need to escalate your response
to seriously yeah and even if that's
getting the dog
taking a beat packing your bags leaving
for a little bit like he needs to
realize that what he did was absolutely
psychotic behavior period Point Blank
and that you know literally you [ __ ]
around and you find out actions have
consequences like you want to be a dog
Napper you're not going to have your
wife at home
yeah because like the the way the fact
that like his response was to hurt you
so deeply to take someone's dog away and
like not know where they are and like
put them in a constant state of like
panic
is a really really evil thing to do like
I'm gonna give him the benefit of the
doubt and say that he didn't take the
dog so that to cause you harm he took
the dog so that he could get his way and
the dog wouldn't get fixed if the dog's
not here she can't take the dog to the
appointment I think that hurting you and
like making you worried was an
unfortunate byproduct of that I don't
think he was like trying to hurt you he
was just doing anything to get his way
but not even thinking about his wife's
feelings like that's so mean
yeah no because his way and his feelings
are more important no this is really
this is the biggest red flag I've ever
seen in my life it's not even a flag
it's a [ __ ]
yeah it just it just scares me to think
about like what this person will do with
a child if he's just controlling about a
dog this is the links that he'll go to
that's a really good point it's like
when you think about like shared
children he's going to be even more
impassionate about a decision no matter
this isn't even like a huge decision
like imagine like a real decision with
kids like that has real implications and
you guys disagree
and it seems like he like this is such a
weird Hill to die on yeah
so I would also want to know like why
he's dying on this hill you know maybe
there's a childhood trauma or something
right
um but barring that
immediately things to do immediately is
to put on an act concede get the dog
back just so we know the dog is back
with you and safe and then you and the
dog have to go somewhere like go to your
mom's go somewhere go to a friend's a
hotel
you like absolutely need to show him how
seriously not [ __ ] okay this is like
and how serious you're taking it like I
would even go so far as to like put him
on a no contact for like a week yeah and
you need and in that week you need to
think you need to think back and you
know and of course write us an update
assess and you need to update us I'm
very disturbed by this it's really I
think there I've heard you know many
stories of like people who break up or
they have Partners who are you know like
borderline abusive and like manipulative
like using the dog as collateral because
you know they know how much their wife
or their girlfriend loves the dog and
like stealing the dog dogs are often
used as like ponds and chess pieces in
relationships that it's so [ __ ] up
and let's not forget like it's your dog
so in a legal sense like if we're going
to be legal the dog is yours
yes
um I'm really sorry you're going through
that that's if I didn't know where Theo
was for I mean she wrote in on Tuesday
morning and this happened Monday night
so it's been now like 36 hours without
your dog I'm really sorry like I
I think you I'm immediate plan get the
dog back yeah then we'll figure it out
and write in again because I would love
to help you once you get the dog back
yes keep us posted and I'm so sorry
going through that but thank you for
writing and I hope we were helpful and
if anyone wants to write in again it's
deer toasters gmail.com
that is our episode and that is our
final episode of the week so anything
you want to say to the peeps before we
let them go for Thanksgiving uh just
that we're having a huge sale over at
toastmarch.com up to 50 off on all like
not new items so the new holiday
collection isn't on sale but everything
over the years over the past redheads on
sale not like other girls high learn 100
beautiful standing smart up to 50 off
there's even some old like last year's
holiday merch yeah so there is
technically holiday stuff on sale up to
50 off the prices are insane so head
over to toastmarch.com and you can get
this season's holiday collection and
some of the sale items the sale is
already on so just head over to the
sales section and Shop
and have a great weekend don't forget to
be thankful for the toast and your girls
and yeah have a great holiday we love
you guys thank you so much for listening
to the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found
that's Spotify iTunes Stitcher public
radio iheartradiocastbox all the places
so I'd be listening to podcast find us
the toast Libra five-star review about
how wickedly talented we are have an
amazing holiday weekend we'll see you
guys back in studio on Monday bye bye